mevrouw van kroonhoven van nse
voorzitter dan 3 moties van onze kant eertje
eentje over het vastlopen van het proces
de kamer gehoord de beraadslaging
overwegende dat het kabinet
vaak heeft aangegeven dat de compensatie
van de gedupeerden
prioriteit heeft
constaterende dat de regering
ruim 3 jaar geleden is begonnen
met het herstellen van de schade
in het toeslagenschandaal
en constaterende dat tot nu toe ruim
67.000 gedupeerden zich hebben gemeld
en hiervan 1 grote groep nog niet of nog niet volledig
is geholpen constaterende
dat de voorspel de kosten van hersteloperatie
zijn opgelopen van 300 miljoen
naar 7 2 miljard en verder zullen oplopen
constaterende dat dossiers
nog steeds niet goed geleverd worden
zwartgelakt zijn
en dat de regering
stelselmatig alle wettelijke termijnen overschrijdt
constaterende
dat het leven van 1 Groot aantal gedupeerden
nog steeds stil staat
spreekt uit dat de hersteloperatie
op 1 aantal punten is vastgelopen
en op 1 aantal punten dreigt vast te lopen
en roept het kabinet
op haar eerder gemaakte afspraken richting de
gedupeerden na te komen en gaat over
tot de orde van de dag
eentje over
uniform beleid voor hersteloperaties waar wij
overwegende dat op dit moment in Nederland
meerdere hersteloperaties
plaatsvinden als gevolg van 1 onrechtmatige overheid
overwegende
dat de overheid op dit moment hersteloperaties
afzonderlijk
opzet uitvoert en hierdoor uniform overheidsbeleid
ontbreekt overwegende dat uniform hersteloperatie
zal zorg voor zekerheid bij gedupeerden en betreffende
doelen uitvoeringsorganisaties
verzoekt de regering
nieuwe hersteloperaties
als gevolg van 1 onrechtmatige overheidsstaat
uniformeren en dit
te beleggen bij het ministerie van binnenlandse zaken
verzoekt de regering
het uniform beleid en de kaderwet vast te leggen
en de kamer over de voortgang hiervan
binnen 1/2 jaar te rapporteren
gaat over tot de orde van de dag
tenslotte ik HEB nog 20 seconden over
dat je zonder dossier je rechten kan halen
de kamer gehoord de beraadslaging
overwegende dat alleen
op basis van 1 compleet dossier
kan worden vastgesteld wat de schade
is van de gedupeerden
in het toeslagenschandaal
overwegende dat gedupeerden zonder informatie
geen compleet beeld kunnen vormen
van wat er is gebeurd en hoe Groot hun schade is
overwegende het uitvoerend bestuursorgaan
als schadeveroorzaker
wel alle stukken beschikt
en weet wat 1 schending oplevert
overwegende dat bij het verstrekken van oude dossiers
nog steeds wordt uitgegaan van wantrouwen
in plaats van vertrouwen
verzoekt de regering gedupeerden het volledige
ongelakte dossier te verstrekken
en gaat over tot de orde van de dag
dank u wel laten we spreken van De Zijde van de kamer